okay it's time for hatred mail quick
reminder about what we mean by hatred
mail because it's time to make America
hate again hatred mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom George Soros
a staple of hatred mail any good
anti-semitic conspiracy theory will
often mention George Soros but usually
just by actually saying his name this
week's hatred I guess thinks that they
are being creative by coming up with a
new nickname for George Soros take a
listen David is a controlled opposition
guess who controls him hmm
George II sore nuts watching Pakman is
like watching the twilight zone almost
everything he says is backwards weak try
Davy phony left-wing anti-catholic Jew
that's interesting are they saying that
I'm not actually an anti-catholic Jew in
the sense that I'm a phony or are they
saying that I am a phony and all of
those other things it's not super clear
there's sort of a grammatical ambiguity
as it's often common in hatred mail the
best thing you can do if you don't like
the message from the hatreds is send
them a middle finger salute by signing
up for a membership with the coupon code
hatred for th8 e are io t for 0 when you
apply that coupon code to the membership
of your choice you say 40% and many many
hatreds get upset because their messages
are failing they are growing support for
the David Pakman show